it's one of the alleged war crimes the
International Criminal Court may
investigate the targeted killing of
unarmed protesters along gauzes border
fence with Israel chief prosecutor fatou
Bensouda says she's satisfied war crimes
have been or are being committed in the
Gaza Strip and the West Bank including
occupied East Jerusalem she says because
of the complexity of the situation she
will ask the ICC to rule on the
territories on which it has jurisdiction
Palestinians welcomed what they call a
long overdue investigation while hoping
that the ICC will hold those who are
committing crimes against our people
against our land and the crimes that are
outlined in the Rome Statute accountable
to their crimes and that no more crimes
are being committed on the Palestinian
land which will basically set the stage
for ending occupation and thus opening
the path for a conclusion of this
conflict but Israel's Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu says the court has no
jurisdiction to investigate in the
Palestinian territories this is a dark
day for truth and justice
the ICC prosecutor has apparently
decided not to dismiss outright the
Palestinian claim against the State of
Israel this is a baseless in a rageous
decision the court has no jurisdiction
in this case the ICC only has
jurisdiction over petitions submitted by
sovereign states but there's never been
a Palestinian state the court based in
the Netherlands will only investigate
alleged crimes committed after June 2014
when Palestine became part of the ICC
jurisdiction in the past five years
thousands of new legal settlement units
were developed along with the
confiscation of Palestinian lands and
demolition of their homes Israel's
response isn't unexpected it says the
ICC lacks validity over the
israeli-palestinian conflict since
Israel is not a member of the court and
Palestine is not a state even though the
united nation granted palestine the
status of non-member state seven years
ago palestinian leaders say
any crimes committed on Palestinian
territory must fall under the court's
jurisdiction Neda Ibrahim Al Jazeera
Ramallah